はじめ「そもそもこれがさーｧｧｰ」
あったかくなるか、っていう問題だよね
ぃやっ、なるでしょう
まさき「なるよねぇ」
えー、やっぱ †オルタナチャンネル† みたいにさー
赤くなんのかなァ？///
どーもっ！マサキ取締役と！
(ﾌﾟｨｰｰｰﾝ)
はじめしゃちょー です！
みなさん、最近youtubeで何が流行ってるか知ってますか？
SO!!!!!!!
鉄球を1000℃に熱して！
それを使って色んなものを、、、溶かします
アブナーイ！！！
いやっ　いいんですけどぉ・・・
そうです
ちょっと今 鉄球を1000℃に やったらぁ
すごい溶けるんデス
なんか物とか置いてあっても
1000℃の鉄球が熱すぎてっ
ドンドン物が溶けて　ホントすごい！！！！
HUHUHU
Doctorはじめは、素直にそう思ったので！
今回やってみようと思います
やってみたいですよね？？
やってみたいですね
そのままぁ！
こぅ、1000℃の鉄球をやったら
もぅ　ホントにただの丸パクリになっちゃうんで
今回Doctorはじめは
とあるものを準備しました！
((ﾄﾞｯｺﾞｫﾝ))
はっ、はっ///
こちら
desu
よくyoutubeで見るのって小さいっしょ？く%$#
まさき「うん」
まさき「割とこんぐらいのね・・・」
デショ？！
普段熱せられるあの鉄球たちよりも
はるかに大きいサイズの、砲丸でございます
今回こちらを熱すると、ひょっとしたら
鉄球よりもすげーパワーになるかもしれない
そもそも
重いので下に行く重力も強い！
かつ、熱せられる  体積も大きいので、
より大きな熱エネルギーを持ったまま、
重い重力を維持して、
下に向かう
直下運動するかもしれない
というわけで今回は！
この！
を
に熱して！
でかい氷を準備したので、
そこに！
させてみようと
思います
では参るッッ！！
足ッ、溶けたらどうしよう・・・
転がってきてさ・・・(ﾃｹ↑ﾃｹ↑ﾃｹ↑ﾃｹ↑ﾃｹ↑ﾃｹ↑↑)
はい！というわけで
こちらには氷！ドンドン積み重ねていきます
ホントにやりたいだけなんだよね～
まさき「えっへっへ」
Now loading...
hai!
というわけで！氷の準備が完了しました！
本当に危ないので真似しないで下さい。
場所の許可もとっておりますぅ
火事にも細心の注意を払っております
くれぐれも、マネしないようにしてください！
たぶんペンチとかじゃ持てないので
ボウルに熱したやつをそのまま入れて
がんばってこーやってぇ
オトシマス！
完璧じゃないッスか・・・？
まさき「ひっひっひ(｀´）」
温めていきます！
((ﾎﾞｫｫｫ))
uwa-
((んﾎﾞｯ))
ｺﾜｲｺﾜｲkowai
Now Heating...
そろそろやめるか？
まさき「こんくらいでいんじゃん？」
んじゃあ止めまーす！！！
はっ！ヤバイ！
色が！やばい！色がやばい！
じゃぁ！持ちますっ！
いくよ？いくよっ？
まさき「っぇｺﾜｲｺﾜｲｺﾜｲ」
はい！はい...
ｶﾗｶﾗｶﾗ
マジあつい！
まさき「ほんとに？」
ホントにあつい！
もう皿が持てない！あつくて・・・
ちょっとまってｗｗｗ
まさき「気を付けてｷｦﾂｹﾃ？」
おっけおっけ
いきますっ
おっけぇ、着地！
オトシマス！
ｼﾞｩｩｰｰ
ゆっくりいくよ？ゆっくりいくよ
まさき「はいっ、はい」
ｶﾗｶﾗｶﾗ
もー着地した！触っていいよ！さわっていいよ！
おっけ
いくよ...？
じゅ～～！(水が熱せられる音)
ﾎﾟｰﾝ
きた！
(Now Loading...)
あ～、でもここから伸びるんじゃないのぉ？？
まさき「ｳｰﾝ」
多分、熱すごい含んでるから！こっから#$&#$
(Now Melting...)
えっ、え！みて？動いてるんだよ？中で！
ホラ
まだずーーっと動いてます...
ちょっと止まったっぽいんですけどもぉ～
うん。完全に冷えましたァ！
まさき「ｱｰ,ﾎﾝﾄﾀﾞｰ」
は～
というわけで何枚行ったんだろう・・・
三段目ぐらいまでは溶けました！
ま～ひとまず！
いやいや！すごいすごい
ﾏｻｷ「すごい！てか・・・」
はじめ「すごい！」
まさき「でも ｳ...ｳﾂｸｼ~よね　みてて」
美しい！そう！
はじめ「アートなんだよねっ！」
まさき「ﾈｰ」
イリュージョンだった！完全に！
まさき「ほんとに・・・」